Hola Muy Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña Ulises cortes catedrático
de Inteligencia artificial de la
Universidad politécnica de Cataluña
coordinador científico del grupo de
Inteligencia artificial de alto
rendimiento en el centro de
supercomputación de Barcelona todo un
referente a nivel internacional en lo
que son las investigaciones sobre este
tema con él vamos a hablar por supuesto
de Inteligencia artificial un terreno
que nos ha resultado durante mucho
tiempo y todavía puede resultarnos a un
lejano incluso más vinculado al ámbito
de la ciencia ficción no obstante
comienza a colarse cada vez más en
nuestra vida si por eso en estos
momentos está en el centro de muchísimos
debates y por eso con Ulises vamos a
tener una mirada crítica sobre este tema
Ulises cortes Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de Franz 24
Muchas gracias por la invitación Bueno
Ulises vamos a comenzar por lo siguiente
porque hay una Concepción generalizada
no de lo que es la Inteligencia
artificial Como aquella que busca crear
tecnologías que tengan las mismas
capacidades que los seres humanos verdad
pero es esto así de qué hablamos cuando
hablamos de Inteligencia artificial
Ulises
bueno La idea es entender Cuáles son los
procesos que yacen en la inteligencia
animal en particular la humana porque
consideramos más avanzada
poderlos Reproducir con una computadora
o con un conjunto de computadoras y una
vez que hemos entendido Cómo funciona la
inteligencia animal lo que queremos es
aplicarla en distintos
aspectos de la vida cotidiana de los
como una posible capacidades
Ulises más de mil expertos en lo que es
Inteligencia artificial entre ellos por
supuesto usted y otros muy reconocidos
también no como elon musk Steve bosniac
firmaron una carta abierta hace ya
varios días donde piden que los
laboratorios pongan Una pausa Esta
carrera de esta tecnología no
concretamente lo que pidieron fue una
pausa de seis meses en lo que es el
desarrollo en los sistemas más potentes
que él recientemente lanzado chat gpt
cuatro por qué es necesario pausar la
Inteligencia artificial Qué riesgos y
Qué desafíos conlleva este desarrollo
tan acelerado
A ver no no se pide parar el desarrollo
de la Inteligencia artificial se pide
parar el la experimentación social con
estas herramientas de manera
indiscriminada que son dos cosas muy
distintas sí empresas que producen este
tipo de herramientas tiene una posición
de poder asimétrico y lo que han
conseguido es que haya muchos ciudadanos
en todas partes del mundo que utilicen
esas herramientas y estas compañías
aprenden de la interacción con estas
máquinas ese aprendizaje
les aumentar su capacidad de penetración
y sobre todo mejorar la herramienta de
tal manera de convertirse en los líderes
de una una tecnología que puede cambiar
la forma en la que vivimos las
relaciones sociales la economía etcétera
y lo que queremos es que no es razonable
que una tecnología que no ha sido
certificada por ningún estado esté
circulando de una manera tan rápida y
tan abierta
hablemos ahora de la polémica y tantos
debates no que están surgiendo por estos
días a partir del chat gpt está causando
furor muchísimas personas hablando de
sus grandes capacidades en lo que son
las respuestas para desarrollar textos
de diversos tipos se abren múltiples
aristas de debate pero quisiera
concentrarme en una que me ha parecido
interesante voy a citar al filósofo
Erick sadding que él hizo un análisis
que fue publicado en el diario argentino
página 12 allí él planteaba Algo así
como que se trata todo esto también de
un proceso epigenético en el que está en
marcha De cierto modo nuestra mente no
que está constituida para ser plenamente
activa y que según este filósofo se
dejará llevar por estos sistemas
reduciendo paulatinamente el uso de
nuestras facultades expresivas coincide
en algún punto usted con este análisis
las tecnologías impactan en nuestra
subjetividades cómo lo hacen estas
Este tipo de herramientas no están
pensadas para hacer al 100% verosímiles
y por lo tanto las respuestas que dan no
son completamente verdaderas si luego
estas herramientas se utilizan para
generar nuevos contenidos que irán a
internet la calidad de la información
que está en internet disminuirá esto es
claro están atacando la calidad de la
información y generando desinformación a
lo que se refiere el filósofo también es
que si tú no tienes que Esforzarte para
realizar una tarea generar una carta
escribir un ensayo
a desarrollar cualquier tipo de tarea
cognitiva importante entonces luego no
tendrás estas capacidades disponibles y
por lo tanto la cultura del esfuerzo que
ha sido la base de nuestro desarrollo
paulatinamente se verá minada
esto hablo de la gran mayoría de las
personas que no tienen una formación
adecuada un espíritu crítico adecuado
para personas información
consultar unas herramientas muy útiles
para acelerar cierto tipo de procesos lo
que tenemos que tener en cuenta es que
son tecnologías que no deberían estar
disponibles de momento para todo el
mundo hasta que no tengamos claro Cuál
es su alcance claro precisamente a eso
hacía referencia no sobre lo que hay que
pausar No ese esa accesibilidad no por
parte de las poblaciones verdad Acá
entra también un tema clave ustedes
recién comenzaba a desarrollarlo cuando
mencionaba esto de información de
calidad no con la Inteligencia
artificial y ya en un contexto bastante
crítico verdad en materia de circulación
de fake news o noticias falsas estas
tecnologías podrían dificultar aún más
el acceso a información veraz confiable
y de calidad
Y si eso lo sumas a la capacidad de
recomendación que tiene estas
herramientas puedes modificar de una
forma mayoritaria la información a la
calidad de la opinión crítica que tienen
los ciudadanos y podría ser un ataque
directo a las democracias no hay que no
hace falta ir muy atrás para recordar el
caso de capricha analítica donde se
Facebook se utilizó para modificar la
opinión de los votantes americanos en la
elección de Donald Trump o
no Perdón continúe continúe no quise
interrumpirlo Sí sí el brexit también se
utilizó de estas herramientas para
modificar la posición de los ciudadanos
ingleses a la hora de
separarse de la Unión Europea
absolutamente
hay que recordar que los gobiernos no
han hecho nada para prevenir esta
entrada de manera masiva en nuestras
casas en nuestra vida cotidiana
absolutamente eso también son claves
para tomar todo tipo de decisiones y las
consecuencias políticas como usted bien
decía son de muchísima importancia ahora
las tecnologías funcionan en virtud de
una cantidad de datos No que los seres
humanos le van dando O sea hay una
dimensión técnica como pero también como
en todas las tecnologías hay una
dimensión humana estas tecnologías son
generadas por personas por una sociedad
verdad y acá entra el debate sobre qué
realidades y qué sesgos no raciales
económicos culturales de género de todo
tipo incorporan y también refuerzan
estos nuevos sistemas tecnológicos
aquí hay dos cosas estas herramientas
han sido producidas por empresas cuyo
objetivo es
dinero y posición económica los sesgos
que puedan tener están
fundamentalmente
creados por la selección de la
información que es ingente
y que han terminado por generar Este
modelo que además ellos son incapaces de
explicar una de las cosas pedimos a esta
tecnología es que sea transparente
explicable el número de nodos que tiene
que ya superan los billones de nodos
disponibles no permite ninguna
explicación humana razonable y el sesgo
existe
y lo que no podemos pensar es que estas
compañías son hermanitas de la Caridad y
lo que están haciendo tiene un sentido
muy claro de intento de manipular la
forma en la que la economía y las
relaciones sociales ocurren hoy en día
muy interesante este análisis sobre los
intereses no Ulises que subyacen a al
desarrollo de estas tecnologías quisiera
abordar ahora un tema que tiene muchas
miradas puestas sobre él y me refiero al
impacto de la Inteligencia artificial en
el campo laboral no en este plano un
informe reciente del banco de inversión
goldman sachs haberte que podrían
llegarse a reemplazar el equivalente a
300 millones de empleos de tiempo
completo le preocupa este tema
muchísimo pero hay que recordar que este
informe de
golden sachs solamente está pensado para
los grandes países del abcd Claro en
países donde la
la alfabetización digital es menor el
impacto será mucho mayor
Y eso no está considerado porque hay
muchas tareas que serán fácilmente
reemplazables por ejemplo piense usted
en todos estos países donde tienen
personas que trabajan en los llamados
call centers y todos esos puestos de
trabajo pueden desaparecer porque se
pueden generar voces y sistemas de
respuesta automatizados y eso acabará de
manera definitiva con estos trabajos eso
es solamente una idea habrá muchísimos
puestos de trabajo que se verán
afectados Es cierto que aparecerán
nuevos puestos de trabajo pero serán muy
pocos y muy bien remunerados y esto lo
que generará será nuevas brechas no solo
digitales sino también económicas a eso
apuntaba mi próxima pregunta Ulises la
brecha digital se va a expandir va a
aumentar de significativamente cómo
gestionar esto
Bueno aquí es un problema político Qué
hacen los gobiernos que no están
tomando medidas ya por ejemplo como las
que ha tomado Italia o hoy se ha sabido
que tanto china como Estados Unidos
están poniendo primeros pasos para hacer
una legislación en España y en Francia
Parece ser que están también a punto de
lanzar una una forma de legislación si
la sociedad no tiene capacidad de
reacción porque no está informada y los
gobiernos por la razón que sea no están
actuando estas empresas que ocupan las
zonas grises de la legislación tomarán
cada vez posiciones más más avanzadas me
gustaría hacer Sí claro
en la capacidad
necesaria
está al alcance de muy pocos países en
toda América Latina solo Brasil tiene
capacidad de cómputo suficiente como
para generar un modelo de este tipo
Gracias Ulises cortes por su presencia
en la entrevista de Franz 24
Hasta luego Hasta luego a nuestra
Providencia le invitamos a seguir
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también en transmitir
cuatro punto com si han junto a nosotros
[Música]